this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream and nebula where you can
watch the next episode of our brand new
series becoming human and a field notes
companion video about the hilarious
reality of studying sloths in the field
the rainforest is a beautiful but deadly
place
it's an ecosystem with immensely High
biodiversity and intense competition
plants battle for sunlight insects
battle for territory most animals face
the constant risk of predation death by
disease poisoning from plants or a
venomous bite
this ecosystem is suited to only the
hardiest most formidable creatures
stay alive here many prey animals rely
on speed teamwork or sheer Ingenuity and
yet throughout the rainforests of
Central and South America lives this
creature not quick not collaborative and
presumably not very smart sloths were
first described in Western science by
unimpressed French naturalist George
Buffon in 1749 he wrote slowness
habitual pain and stupidity are the
results of this strange and bungled
Confirmation these sloths are the lowest
form of existence one more defect would
have made their lives impossible
those sloths are indeed cute at first
glance they do have several traits that
made Buffon think so little of them
sloths spend their days in the Treetops
barely moving when they do decide to
move they crawl at a Breakneck pace of
15 feet per minute
some sloths even spend their entire life
in the same tree they were born in never
bothering to venture in any direction
for any reason
to some their ongoing survival seems
like an actual mistake as if an
evolutionary blunder has allowed them to
slip through the cracks
but to view sloths as useless is to see
them from a narrow human lens
we humans equate Speed and Agility with
adaptive Fitness since for our bipedal
species these traits have been
beneficial to survival in Our Minds The
Reason something is slow is because it
sucks at being fast that slowness is the
inferior opposite to speed
but sloths Force us to re-examine this
paradigm for a sloth slowness isn't a
defect but a feature and their slow
paced lifestyle is in fact the perfect
way for them to survive in their dense
and chaotic habitat and the adaptations
surrounding the slowness of sloths are
really really strange from their
metabolism to their slow rate of
digestion to their limb muscles bones
and fur no other animal is even remotely
similar to the sloth because as strange
as a sloth might appear on the outside
it only gets weirder the closer you look
foreign
tree sloths are masters of stealth a far
cry from house sloths originated on this
planet their unrecognizable compared to
their ground sloth ancestors like
megatherium americanum one of the
largest land mammals to have ever
existed
weighing up to four tons and measuring
up to 6 meters or 20 feet in length from
head to tail sadly these giant sloths
went extinct and today there are only
six species of sloths all of them tree
sloths from two different families the
two-toed and three-toed sloths they live
in or near canopies of tropical
rainforests of Central and South America
their slow stealthy movement essential
in keeping them hidden from their
predators such as jungle cats and Harpy
eagles
these Predators hunt largely with their
eyesight so moving slowly and making no
sudden movements helps to conceal the
sloths
but moving around high in the trees is
no easy feat for any animal
getting around safely requires strength
agility and balance and it's an
evolutionary challenge that has led to
many different adaptive strategies among
arboreal mammals
some species of arboreal animal
incorporate their tails into their
movement or into their suspensory
behaviors porcupines silky anteaters
spider monkeys and opossums use a
prehensile tail to grasp branches for
extra support and stability other
animals use speed and momentum to get
around in the trees by a type of
locomotion called brachiation it's used
mainly by monkeys and apes and allows
them to propel themselves through the
canopy by swinging from one hold to
another by the arms it's both fast and
energy efficient
by swinging like a pendulum potential
and kinetic energy is exchanged back and
forth a brachiating primate can make use
of this conservation of momentum and the
metabolic recovery of energy as it goes
but this locomotor behavior requires a
good deal of strength
if you've ever tried to brachiate or arm
swing as an adult like swing across the
monkey bars or if you've ever attempted
one of those hang for 100 seconds
Carnival scams you've probably been
disappointed by your performance
to move around by your arms or to hang
like this is hard but even more
challenging than arm swinging
brachiation would be to try to do the
monkey bars slowly and even harder than
hanging for 100 seconds would be hanging
for 10 minutes with one hand
sloths which have no supporting
prehensile tail and do not use pendular
exchanges of energy to make things
easier for themselves do all of this
routinely seemingly with the greatest of
ease a sloth can easily suspend its
entire body weight from a single limb
for over 10 minutes they can brace
themselves between two branches in the
crucifix position for even longer so
just by a back of the envelope
calculation I worked out that a sloth is
about two times stronger than your
average human and yet when you look at
their limb their muscles are thin and
ropey they do not look like they would
be that strong to understand the
baffling strength of sloths I talked to
Dr Mike Butcher professor of zoology and
biomechanics at Youngstown State
University their total body skeletal
muscle mass is only roughly 23.5 to 24
percent compare that to you you're 44
percent so they have significantly less
muscle so per gram of muscle tissue
they're getting a lot of force out of
their muscles so how are they able to
perform such Feats of Strength by
dissecting mapping weighing and
measuring each of the 50 22 muscles
found in the forelimb of three-toed
sloths researchers started to get closer
to an answer
they started by examining the forelin
where there are two major groupings of
muscles flexors and extensors
flexors do work to bend a joint for
example when you flex your biceps your
elbow flexors contract and pull on the
forearm segment creating a bending or
rotational movement of the elbow joint
to move your hand upwards flexor muscles
are used for pulling Motions like doing
a pull-up extensors serve the opposite
function extending and straightening
joints these types of muscles are
generally used for pressing motions
when you you and me are walking we're an
upright
we expect
our extensor muscles are the ones that
are most important for keeping us
upright and supporting our body weight
but in sloths this story is totally
flipped
when you're upside down those muscle
activations must change accordingly it's
as if the nervous system has to rewire
or retool itself to now use flexor
muscles as the main supporting muscles
in sloths the flexors are more well
developed than the extensors this means
that the muscles that sloths use to grip
and pull are larger than those that
extend the researchers also found that
the type of individual fibers within the
muscle helps give the sloth remarkable
grip strength the muscle fibers in the
digital flexor musculature become
progressively more angled towards the
forefoot when the fibers are aligned in
this way that is less parallel to the
length of the muscle belly they can
produce more Force this phenomenon is
known as penation
but it's not just how the sloth's
muscles are built that gives them
Incredible strength it's how they use
them
the force velocity relationship is a
fundamental principle of skeletal muscle
physiology the data in this curve shows
an inverse relationship between force
and velocity meaning that an increase in
force would cause a decrease in velocity
and vice versa
and the faster that a muscle contracts
we call that contractile velocity
the less force that a muscle is capable
of producing so what do you think the
strategy is that sloths have adopted
they can track their muscles very slowly
so if you contract your muscle more
slowly you're enhancing the amount of
force that you can get out of them and
it has the cost benefit of not consuming
a lot of energy to contract your muscles
slowly and forcefully for these reasons
three-toed sloths have a relative grip
strength that approximates 100 percent
of their body weight by comparison the
average grip strength for a human is
around 25 to 45 percent of their body
weight which may explain why we don't do
so well in those hang for 100 seconds
Carnival gimmicks with all these amazing
adaptations sloths can move about the
canopy with a surprising acrobatic Grace
and hang for basically indefinite
periods of time
but things don't always go smoothly for
the sloths Dr Becky Cliff is the founder
of the sloth conservation foundation and
has studied sloths for many years
one of her projects examines sloth
movement and behavior using small radio
transmitter backpacks
and when the project began she kept
getting startling signals what we'd get
back from the backpack dataris would
have these nice sloth climbing signals
and then would have whoosh and you're
like what has happened
um and it took us a really long time to
figure out what these crazy signals were
but it was the sloth falling out the
tree and each individual does it on
average once a week for its entire life
and they're not falling from a short
height they're falling from like 100
meters in the air
um and they bounced a little bit when
they hit the floor and then they get up
and they climb the tree again and
they're absolutely fine
but the sloths don't fall because they
lose their grip they just miscalculate a
bit on which branches to climb they like
to eat the leaves on the very tips of
the branches and these branches are very
flimsy and don't often take their weight
so they do often fall just by branches
breaking and things
luckily their ribs are remarkably
flexible allowing them to survive these
Falls the two-toed sloth even has 46 of
them more than any other mammal for
reference we have 24 but if it weren't
for the sloth's strange diet they might
not take these risks at all
sloths are profoundly particular
creatures even though there are hundreds
of types of vegetation in tropical
rainforests three-toed sloths usually
only eat the leaves of a few types of
trees and of these leaves they prefer
the youngest leaves growing on the
crowns of the trees eating leaves and
leaves only is a pretty difficult way to
get nutrition the leaves have a high
proportion of hard to digest cellulose
and mature leaves don't have many
calories
so how does this strategy work for them
the key to it all is their four
chambered stomach the first three
stomachs are fermentation Chambers where
leaves are broken down by symbiotic
bacteria the resulting product of that
is then broken down in the fourth
stomach by acids and enzymes this is a
lot like how cows digest their food but
usually fullivores compensate for the
low calorie content of leaves by eating
a lot of them and digesting them quickly
but sloths don't have that option it can
take up to 50 days for them to fully
digest a single leaf and this slow
digestion means they also only need to
poop around once per week which they
dutifully climb all the way down out of
their tree to do one of the only reasons
they would ever leave the trees
and once they're doing their business
they make sure to do it with style
the poop dances and something that all
sloths do when they um go to the
bathroom which they only do once a week
so they climb down from their favorite
tree they do the poop dance on the floor
which it looks like they're twerking
kind of in slow motion what they're
actually doing is trying to dig a little
hole using their bum
so they wiggle around and then they poop
in the hole and then they do another
poop dance to bury it and they climb
back up the tree but it does look
absolutely ridiculous
the reason for this Herculean effort
just to poop is thought to be to conceal
their scent poop raining down from the
Treetops would leave a pretty big scent
Trail leading Predators right to the
perpetrator of that smell and even
though they only poop once a week their
stomach is literally always full they
can't eat more until what's in their
stomach has already passed so like with
everything else they have to ingest
their food slowly
three-toed sloths have been observed to
eat on average only 17 grams of food per
day which is like three leaves per day
eating such little food would make any
other similarly sized mammal starve to
death
but sloths have another trick up their
sleeve they have the slowest metabolism
of any mammal in the animal kingdom
rivaled only by mammals deep in
hibernation having such a slow
metabolism means that they have
tremendously low energy needs three-toed
sloths burn as little as 130 calories
per day two toad sloths around 300
calories per day
and their metabolism is even weirder
than it seems on first glance the first
weird thing is that sloths don't need to
maintain a stable internal temperature
like most other mammals instead their
internal temperature changes with the
temperature outside and it can fluctuate
as much as 10 degrees Celsius
this is more like how the ectotherms
work like lizards aka the cold-blooded
animals by allowing their body
temperature to fluctuate with the
temperature outside sloths save a lot of
energy up to about 32 degrees Celsius
sloths would have you convinced that
they are cold-blooded creatures
but any hotter than this point things
get even weirder again as sloths do
something different than any other
animal they begin to actively depress
their metabolism without entering a
state of estivation as far as we know
this is completely unique in the animal
kingdom entering into estivation or
hibernation would mean shutting almost
everything down reducing the heart rate
drastically reducing body temperature
and becoming unresponsive it's a long
and serious process for an animal to do
this but sloths manage to reduce their
metabolism quickly while they're awake
and able to move around they can also do
it for very short periods and can
reverse it as soon as temperatures cool
down
by depressing their metabolism they are
simultaneously saving energy and also
reducing the amount of metabolic heat
being produced by their body therefore
staying a little bit cooler so are
sloths ectotherms or endotherms the
answer is neither or maybe both sloths
exist in a transitional State between
cold-bloodedness and warm-bloodedness a
state called heterothermy and while
saving energy in the form of moving
slowly digesting slowly pooping
infrequently clearly have their adaptive
benefit they also have some surprising
side effects side effects that look like
a curious Quirk but in fact provide
another layer of protection for the
sloth
staying hidden is the only way a sloth
can survive and sloths have become true
masters of camouflage their slow
movements allow them to blend in with
the swaying of branches and so does
their Mossy green fur a fur so unique
that it's its own microcosm of Abundant
Life both types of sloths have a diverse
collection of microorganisms in their
fur including arthropods fungi and algae
including some species that only exist
within the ecosystem aboard the sloth
the cryptoses moths or certain species
of green algae only live in sloth fur
individual hairs of three-toed sloths
have unique cracks which allow the hair
shaft to become saturated with rain
water and allow algae to grow
hydroponically the algae lives its life
being passed directly from mother sloth
to baby sloth and has not been found and
anywhere else Beyond sloth fur and
intriguingly in a roundabout way that
silly sloth poop dance may play a
crucial role in the growth of this algae
when sloths descend to the ground and
poop female kryptosis moths lay their
eggs in the fresh excrement
the larvae then develop entirely within
the poop and adult moths emerge and fly
to the canopy in search of their sloth
fur home
and these moths are crucial for the
algae and sloth fur the moths likely
transport nitrogen up from the piles of
dung allowing the algae to grow and it
turns out this algae is very important
to the sloths they were recently found
to actually consume their algae Gardens
in order to supplement their limited
diet without the poop dance there would
be no moths and without the moths there
would be no nitrogen and thus no algae
and for researchers sloth poop may be
the key for future research endeavors
so one of the projects I'm working on at
the moment is to try and train a dog to
detect sloth poop and then we can start
actually walking transects and being
like oh this many sloths live in this
area based on the number of poop piles
on the floor
um and for the first time we can start
monitoring populations over time and see
how it's changing and then we can show
for the first time sloths are in trouble
they are actually decreasing
um because the current conservation
statuses don't reflect that and that's
based on a lack of data sloths are
currently listed under the least
concerned category because of this lack
of data and without the hard science
it's hard to protect these incredible
animals
it's so hard to get funding for an
animal when they say oh it's loose
concern and so really nobody cares but
actually that's not true and what we're
seeing here is sloths literally being
decimated areas where I knew there were
sloths living three years ago in really
high densities and I've completely void
our sloths so we're literally seeing it
every single day and there's nothing
like documenting this to the to
governments or to The Wider Community to
funders and donors there's just nothing
out there lots of data tons of papers
and hard numbers are going to be needed
to ensure the survival of these
incredible animals and on paper hard
numbers like these are presented in the
format of clean white paper with neat
Black Ink but the way these hard numbers
are collected is never that tidy field
work is the beautiful and messy reality
behind so much of the science we all
know today I studied biology in college
with law lots of hours spent in the lab
and lots of hours writing up papers
this was all well and good but it wasn't
until my first field research trip to
Indonesia that my soul was ignited
every single day was filled with
Adventure both good and bad I learned
firsthand that to collect valuable data
on the populations of critically
endangered frogs it meant trekking
Through Rivers at night stepping in
heaps of vicious fire ants getting
caught in powerful thunderstorms
stumbling upon magnificent and enormous
pythons
this was the science that thrilled me
and the people who do it for a living
are some of the most fascinating people
I have ever met their stories are
literally insane from flesh-eating
bacteria to homicidal elephants to
naming new species and seeing sites no
one has ever seen
fieldwork is the backdrop for some of
the most incredible stories I have ever
heard and our new nebula plus series
field notes aims to capture these exact
stories
I often talk about the science of
incredible animals on this channel and
now we will get to hear from the experts
behind that science the people spending
months years or decades in the field the
people who know these animals better
than anyone else on the planet
I recently returned from Costa Rica
where I had the amazing opportunity to
witness the work going on to study and
conserve sloths there
from tracking the sloths to analyzing
their muscle contractions to learning
about all the enormous efforts in the
works to protect them it was a trip that
opened my eyes to the very tricky and
very rewarding world that is sloth
science the video you just watched
explains the science of sloths in the
field notes episode will show you the
sometimes hilarious reality of trying to
get that science and since we've been
ramping up production like there's no
tomorrow we also have the next episode
of becoming human available on nebula
right now this one about the first tools
our ancestors ever made
once our ancestors became upright hands
became free to start altering the world
around them but the fossil record tells
us that the evolutionary leap into tool
making isn't as straightforward as you
might think
we are cranking out these nebula videos
if you've ever considered signing up now
is the time to do it
the best way to watch field notes and
become a human on nebula is by signing
up to the bundle deal with
curiositystream nebula has partnered
with curiositystream so you get both
streaming services for just 14.79 for
the entire year that's 26 off the usual
price with two great streaming services
for the price of one
so go to curiositystream.com real
science to get in on this incredible
deal and watch all of our new nebula
videos
[Music]